i'm ethan sipley and these are
valuetaining questions with an actor see
i almost [ __ ] it up
i'm ethan sipley and these are
valuetaining questions with an actor
what made you get into acting i grew up
in hollywood and acting seemed like the
absolute easiest job you could have
that's why i got into it you were in two
movies with denzel washington john q and
remember the titans i was in three
movies with denzel washington john q
remember the titans and unstoppable all
right what was your experience like
working with denzel on the third movie i
was very excited because i thought this
was maybe gonna lead to me and denzel
washington becoming like the next
generation of the quarries which didn't
happen and that was disappointing if you
weren't an actor
what else would you be doing if i wasn't
an actor i'd probably be a chef or work
in a restaurant
if you could have dinner with any
historical figure
who would it be and why if i could have
dinner with any historical figure i'd
want to have dinner with marcus aurelius
because i'm a really big fan of his
meditations mermaids have babies or lay
eggs
mermaids definitely lay eggs who would
you want to play you in the movie of
your life
i think in order to really pull off me
today it would have to be chris pratt
why chris pratt i don't know he's got a
[ __ ] dope six-pack
which fictional character would you love
to star in in a movie thor i'd like to
play thor i guess no
they're doing for i meant like the real
four not the marvel thor however the
vikings interpreted norse gods i could
play one of those guys would you rather
run every time or move or scream every
time you speak i don't want to do any of
that i
i definitely don't want to run is it
okay to take your shoes off on the plane
that depends on the quality of your feet
sometimes yes sometimes no what's the
random stat of your life that you want
everyone to know i once rode a
marathon on a rowing machine in three
hours wait can you say that again i rode
a full marathon 49 000 meters on a
rowing machine in three hours it's a
pretty [ __ ] good time who was winning
to fight a grizzly or a gorilla [ __ ] i
think i think a grizzly wins
i think
sorry they have teeth and claws i know
gorillas have teeth too but
they're herbivores so i i don't i think
the bear wins who was winning the bar
fight between will smith and chris rocks
will smith is like twice his size
will smith he's an action guy will smith
wins sorry sorry chris
what's your guilty pleasure
enlightened ice cream makes cleaning our
little spoon little spoon tiny spoon
like little like cocaine-sized spoon
you gotta otherwise it's gone too fast
your favorite cheat meal anything
middle eastern lebanese food shawarma
and um
baba ganoush and pita bread can you cook
it all yeah okay i can't cook that but i
can cook other stuff i'm ethan sipley
thanks for watching valuetaining
questions and please tune in to the
american glutton podcast
[Music]